Welcome back to Quantum Computing in Practice. This is episode 6. Today we're going to focus on one of my favorite
applications of quantum computers, simulating nature. In this episode, we are going to discuss the steps required
to do this for any sort of quantum dynamics problem, which is the problem of finding how the description of a
quantum system changes with time. We'll do this at a high level first and then look into a specific example and walk
through it in detail. namely the 2023 IBM experiment that demonstrated quantum utility. For some quick motivation at
the start, one of the most famous stories that those of us in the field of quantum computing tell again and again,
the story of Richard Fineman giving a lecture at Caltech in 1959 and basically
providing motivation for the entire field for decades to come. The speech was called there's plenty of room at the
bottom. a funny title, but the basic idea was that he was claiming there was still so much rich physics to be
discovered at the microscopic level.
Now, that specific talk wasn't given much heed until the 80s when technology had developed quite a bit. And Feman
also clarified and refined his message over time. He returned to Caltech in the 80s and presented another paper called
simulating nature with computers where he specifically said he wanted to talk about the possibility that there is to
be an exact simulation that the computer will do exactly the same as nature.
essentially being able to get rid of crude approximations of what goes on at the atomic scale and replace them with
computers that understand and harness quantum physics to not just simulate what nature is doing, but emulate it.
Now, recall this timeline graphic I showed in a previous episode. At one end, we had problems that were easy to
solve and will not require any sort of speed up quantum could offer. But at the other end, we have problems that are
very hard and need fault tolerant quantum machines which we don't yet have.
Luckily, we believe that there are quite a few simulation problems that lie here in the middle, which is the region that
we can currently work in. And there are lots of reasons to be excited and intrigued by this prospect because the
simulation of nature is the basis for a lot of exciting application areas. just to name a few. If we could better
simulate nature, we could accelerate the discovery of new materials, create better pharmaceuticals and medicine, or
even explore new physics underlying particle physics or cosmology. But before you or I or anyone can attempt to
apply quantum computing to these exciting areas for now, they will need to understand the basic steps in a
typical simulationbased workflow.
First, you'll want to identify a quantum system of interest. This will inform you about the Hamiltonian governing its time
evolution and a meaningful description of its starting properties or its state.
Then you'll need to find an appropriate method to implement the time evolution of this state. With these ingredients
sorted out, the next steps involve carrying out the actual experiment.
These generally involve optimizing the quantum circuit implementation of the time evolution algorithm, executing the
circuit or circuits on quantum hardware and post-processing the results. So we
can name the basic steps involved in a simulation experiment as follows.
Identifying the system Hamiltonian, Hamiltonian encoding, state preparation, state evolution,
circuit optimization, circuit execution, and post-processing.
But these are quite detailed steps. Remember that the four stages of the Qiskit patterns framework, which helps
us understand how to implement a routine in Kiskit are mapping, circuit optimization, circuit execution, and
post-processing. So these four first steps here are actually all included under the umbrella of mapping and that's
why we spent an entire episode on this first stage and if you missed that please go back and watch the previous episode.
Now let's first walk through what these steps even mean before we dive into any coding. So the first basic thing we need
to do to perform a simulation experiment is to identify the Hamiltonian that describes the system. Sometimes well
often these are wellnown other times we have to put it together from understanding the energy contributions
of the small subsets of the full system like so where hi is the Hamiltonian acting on one of the n subsystems of h.
We will also need to note if the system consists of firmians or bzons if we are dealing with elementary particles. Next,
we need to encode the Hamiltonian and translate it into terms quantum computers can understand. Often times,
these Hamiltonians will be made up of elementary particles or spin systems. If we were simulating firmians or bzons, we
will need to choose an encoding transformation like the Jordan Wigner or Bravi Katev. These transformations will
tell us how to translate the definition of the Hamiltonian written in terms of the original components. the firmians or
bzzons into pi operators which are easily converted into gates on a quantum computer. For example, the Jordan winger
transformation defined here gives a mapping from firmian operators to poly operators. If we are already dealing
with spin 1/2 systems which are very common then we're good to go aside from any possible normalization coefficients
and we don't need to use an encoding scheme. Having encoded the desired Hamiltonian into the quantum computer's
gate set, the next crucial step is to determine the appropriate initial quantum state from which to begin our
simulation. This state should ideally reflect some physical meaning or configuration of the
system under study. For example, if we're interested in exploring the ground state energy of a molecule, we might
start with a heartry faul approximation or another easily preparable ons that has significant overlap with the true
ground state. The choice of initial ground state affects not only the convergence of variational algorithms
like VQE the variational quantum solver but also the accuracy and efficiency of
time evolution or sampling in the quantum phase estimation. In essence, the initial state serves as the
launching point for the computation setting the stage for extracting useful observables about the quantum system
that we're modeling. the preparation of an arbitrary n cubit state where ci are the computational basis states and ai is
each state's respective coefficient and the normalization condition 2 n minus one can generally be approached by
initializing the state with the operator o the starting state would be the all zero standard basis state often written
like this for simplification in general this requires an exponential number of C not gates often times We are
interested in a specific initial state for the system and its preparation can be implemented with a reasonable amount
of resources. Product states for example in which the cubits are not entangled with each other only require single
cubit operations. Now we haven't actually had the opportunity to talk about trotterization
yet though some of you are probably already familiar with it. In essence, trotterization is a method for calculating matrix exponentiation that
uses approximations to handle the exponential nature of non-communive operators. When two operators like HA
and HB don't commute, then we must supply a clever trick and alternatively apply the corresponding exponentials of
eus i ha and eus i hb for n number of
times. the alternating evolution operators are applied. I won't go over the proof here, but I will share a link
to a nice simple proof of this statement in the description. But the take-home message is this. Time evolution is an
important part of mapping too. Trotterization breaks up a continuous interaction into discrete steps that can
be implemented on a quantum computer. After generating the trotterized circuit, we have finally finished the
mapping step. We can now move on to circuit optimization.
To do that, this is what needs to be accomplished. There needs to be a cubit layout that maps the virtual cubits of
your circuit to physical ones on the hardware. This is needed because hardware can have particular topologies
which restrict the direct interaction of physical cubits. While implementation of
a quantum circuit often assumes the ability for any cubit to interact with any other cubit. Then we need to insert
swap gates as needed to route interactions between cubits that are not connected. We need to translate the
gates in our circuit to instruction set architecture or ISA instructions that
can directly be executed on the hardware. Then we need to perform circuit optimizations to minimize the
circuit depth and gate count. This step can also be performed on the virtual circuit. The circuit where the cubits
have not yet been mapped to a device topology yet. But remember much of this is done automatically for you in
Qiskit. We will see exactly how in the next section of this lecture. After the optimization step, we are ready to run
the circuit using a primitive. For most simulation experiments, you are interested in understanding the change
of certain properties of the system with time. So it's likely you will be using the estimator primitive because that
will let you measure the expectation values of observables corresponding to specific properties. Then we will
configure the best options for the estimator which can add error suppression and error mitigation techniques. Finally, we will run the
experiment. The last step is to post-process all the data. This extracts the measured expectation values or if
you're using the sampler, the sample probability distribution in the computational basis. If all one needs
are the expectation values of the observables of interest, these can be directly obtained from the estimator
primitive both in their raw and error mitigated values. Often times one will then use the measured expectation values
for other calculations for other quantities of interest which don't require quantum computation and can be
computed on a classical computer.
Now we are going to walk through a real example from a very influential paper IBM published a couple years ago called
the evidence for utility of quantum computing before fault tolerance. Now this paper which we abbreviate fondly as
the utility paper became a very influential paper in the field of quantum computing almost immediately upon publication.
The overall thesis of the paper is that a noisy quantum computer produced accurate results or expectation values
using 127 cubits and 2,880 gates outside the capabilities of brute
force computation which is the exact simulation of the quantum circuits executed by the hardware. This work was
also important because it showed that a quantum computer could be used to verify or compare results with other
approximate classical methods for quantum simulations such as tensor network algorithms where the solution
was not known by priori. What is also rather cool is that now others using the IBM quantum systems on
the cloud and kiskuit can duplicate and verify these results themselves.
I'm going to walk you through how to do just that. So for this example, we will get a little bit more specific about the
steps involved in mapping this problem into inputs that can be understood by a quantum device. In this case, we will be
simulating the dynamics of the total magnetization of a system of magnetic dipole spins on a lattice in the
presence of an external magnetic field. The system can be described by an icing model with a transverse magnetic field.
We model this with a parameterized quantum circuit where the parameters correspond to the tunable value of the
spin spin or z interaction and the strength of the magnetic field X. Now,
this series is called quantum computing in practice. So, we're also going to discuss procedures in this experiment
that we're going to implement to make the results as good as possible. So next we are going to discuss how to remove
bad cubits or cubits with low gate fidelities or decoherence times which could drastically affect the
experimental outcomes. These bad cubits can occur due to poor prior calibration
or two-level systems interacting with the cubit. Removing some cubits from the hardware native topology corresponds to
considering a system on a lattice described by the resulting topology. We are also going to discuss creating the
parameterized quantum circuit which implements the time evolution of the system via trotterization.
For this purpose, it will be important to identify entangling layers which are a critical part for the main error
mitigation technique we are going to use later on. So at this point I want to make sure that you the audience know
that you can follow along with everything that I'm about to discuss in the tutorial linked below and on the IBM
quantum learning platform. In this tutorial, what you might notice is that we have created a series of helper
functions early in the notebook that we can call upon later to make our lives a little easier. I want to mention these
now, not because it's part of the official or formal process, but because this is often what experimentalists do
in real life to help them run these types of experiments. And it also shows us how we are going to break down our
problem even further. The functions we define in the notebook are as follows. Remove cubit couplings.
Define cubit couplings. Construct the layer couplings. Construct entangling layers. And lastly, define trotterized
circuit. Next, let's talk about layer couplings, which help define how cubits
interact with their neighbors during the simulation. Our quantum devices use something called the heavy hexagonal
layout. A special pattern for connecting cubits. In this layout, we can group the connections called edges into three
separate sets where no two connections in the same set share a cubit. This is
important because on a real quantum computer, we can't run two cubit gates at the same time if they involve the
same cubit. Each cubit can only be involved in one gate at a time. By
dividing all the connections into three layers, we can apply two cubit gates across the entire device in three
rounds, making sure no cubit is used in more than one gate per layer. These
gates implement the ZZ interaction from the Ising model, and they're repeated at each step of the simulation called the
trotder step. twirling modifies the noise in the device so that even a simple noise model
is likely to be accurate. This also makes it possible to accurately learn the noise model and use the obtained
information and error mitigation techniques.
Next, we have to remove our bad cubits from our possible list of physical cubits that we can use for the
experiment. Like I said, a cubit can become bad for a variety of different reasons. Sometimes it's just a bad
calibration, a simple mistake that can be resolved by just calibrating again.
Sometimes it's a bit more complicated and related to something that we call a TLS, which is a two-level interfacial
defect that leads to cubit parameter fluctuations and relaxation. This can be
resolved by warming up the whole system a bit and then cooling it back down. But that takes a while and isn't possible to
do over the cloud. So for now, the easiest thing to do is just exclude them from our list of possible physical
cubits that we'll use. You can identify which cubits are not behaving expected easily from the IBM quantum platform.
You can plot the cubit characteristics there in the platform or download them as a CSV. Then create a list of all the
cubits that you want to exclude and simply remove them from the list of total physical cubits on the device.
All right. Now let's continue on with our mapping step generating our troterized circuit. Now as we showed
earlier trotterization discretizes the time evolution into a series of steps and we need to decide how many steps.
We'll choose six here. But in general the strategy is to balance something called the troder error which is an
algorithmic approximation error with the error arising from decoherence. More troder steps reduces the approximation
error but require deeper quantum circuits which experience more decoherence noise. We will define the
circuit in terms of the theta parameter which is the strength of the external magnetic field layer couplings and the
number of steps and cubits and of course the device back end. Because of the
dependence of the magnetization of the system on the strength of the external magnetic field, it is interesting to
execute the simulation at various values of the magnetic field strength which translate into different angles of RX on
the rotation for RX in the circuit. Now with having generated our circuit, we'll move on to its optimization.
First step here is to define a path manager. Remember in the context of the Qiskit SDK, transpolation refers to the
process of transforming an input circuit into a form that is suitable for execution on a quantum device.
Transpolation typically occurs in a sequence of steps called transpiler passes. A pass manager is an object that
stores a list of transpiler passes and can execute them on a circuit. create a pass manager by initializing a pass
manager object with a list of transpiler passes. In the end, our pass manager
will create an ISA circuit, a circuit that must be written in terms of the backend's instruction set architecture,
which describe the circuit and gates which are native to the backend but lack the timing information needed to run the
circuit. Now we are ready to execute our circuit which is step three of kiskuit patterns. Now as stated before we will
definitely be using the estimator here as our primitive of choice for this experiment since we want to measure the
total magnetization of the system and estimating the expectation value of the observables is what the estimator was
designed for. In this step it will also be crucial to specify our options for error mitigation. We will use zero noise
extrapolation to get the best results possible. Particularly in the tutorial, you will see that we specify two or more
noise factor values at which to evaluate the extrapolated models and specify
probabilistic error amplification as our amplification option. Now, probabilistic
error amplification or PA was really the error mitigation technique method of choice here because it scales so much
better than the other options. And that's what's important when we're working at the level of 100 plus cubits.
Last but not least, run the experiment and it will take some time to complete, but for now, let's reference the data
cued and stored from the tutorial. We will examine the metadata making particular note of the layered gates and
the mitigated layers since we are about to use those to remove a bunch of errors from our raw data. We are almost ready
to plot our final results. But before we do that, let's quickly add an interlude here on what exactly is meant by zero
noise extrapolation or zene. We've covered it briefly in earlier episodes, but to review, zero noise extrapolation
is an error mitigation technique that removes the effects of an unknown noise during circuit execution that can be
scaled in a known way. It assumes expectation values scale with the noise by a known function shown here where the
lambda parameters specify the noise strength and can be amplified. We can implement Z& with the following steps.
First, amplify circuit noise for several noise factors. Lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3, and so on. Run every noise amplified circuit to measure the
expectation value a of lambda 1, a of lambda 2, and so on. And then extrapolate back to the zero noise
limit, the expectation value a of zero.
The main challenge in successfully implementing Z& is to have an accurate model for noise in the expectation value
and to amplify the noise in a known way.
There are three common ways error amplification is implemented for Z& scale pulse duration via calibration
repeat gates in identity cycles and adding noise via sampling py channels.
We call the latter PA. Probabilistic error amplification is the best choice here because pulse stretching is very
computationally costly. Gate folding lacks theoretical guarantees in preserving noise bias. But PA can be
applied to any circuit that can be run with native noise factors but require learning the noise model. PA assumes
that the same layerbased noise model as probabilistic error cancellation.
However, it avoids the sampling overhead that scales exponentially with the circuit noise. To learn the noise model,
we must first identify the unique layers of two cubit operations in the circuit.
For each layer, poly twirl the two cubit gates to ensure that the noise is well described by a damping noise model.
repeat identity pairs of layers at varying depth and finally fit a fidelity or an error for each noise channel. And
of course, while I recommend understanding this method to some extent, doing it by hand in Qiskit is
much more simple as is shown in the tutorial. Now, finally, let's take a look at the plotted data. The dotted
gray line shows the exact results obtained with approximate classical methods with approximation error
converge to a low threshold. As you can see, the raw data for the different factors of noise we chose at the
beginning is a good ways away from this dotted line. The solid blue line shows the data taking into account our Z&
processing. And you can tell right away it's much closer to the exact results.
In summary, the noisy values show high deviation from the exact values. The
mitigated values are close to the exact values, demonstrating the utility of the pea based mitigation technique.
And that essentially concludes this episode. To quickly summarize what we have learned, quantum simulation is one
of the most promising application areas in the short to midterm.
It has wide ranging applications from pharmaceuticals to high energy physics,
material science and more. The utility paper from IBM published in 2023 pointed
the way towards being able to use quantum computers for scientific discovery. And we worked through the
associated tutorial that goes along with that paper in depth. The steps to work through a simulation problem from start
to finish are relatively straightforward, especially once you get the hang of it. And my hope is that you
can from now on use this video and the tutorial as a guide for even more simulation problems in the future.
Thanks for watching and we'll see you next time on Quantum Computing in Practice.